good morning Hank it's Thursday it's my
last video of pizza mess so the
background to this story is that a
couple months before my book turtles all
the way down came out was a pretty
difficult time in my life I was just
completely overwhelmed with worry about
what people would think about the book
and whether I could handle the tour and
publicity stuff and also like how I was
gonna talk about my own mental illness
in the context of the book I was also
really excited to have a book to share
of course but I had to be honest I was
really really scared
okay so tuatara play a role in my new
book and this is the New Zealand 5 cent
piece which I believed to be the only
coin ever minted featuring a tuatara
this one's from 1972 but New Zealand
minted these five cent pieces up until
2006 when they stopped because you know
it was the rational thing to do because
you know money exists to facilitate the
exchange of goods and services which
five cent coins don't do very
effectively also it costs more than five
cents per coin to Mint five cent coins
making their existence especially
astonishing but what if I told you that
some countries still mint coins worth
one-fifth of one nickel now I'm on a
tangent point being New Zealand stopped
making these things over a decade ago
okay so one night I found myself on eBay
trying to fight the creeping sense of
dread with temporal things which I
presume is what drives 90% of eBay's
traffic and I thought I wonder if I
could buy some New Zealand 5 cent coins
turns out I could I was able to buy 23
of them for a total of 22 US dollars and
then I started thinking if I could get a
couple hundred of these New Zealand five
cent pieces I could give them as gifts
to everybody who leaves a gift for us on
our tour but eBay didn't have nearly
enough of them so I reached out to some
Kiwi nerdfighters and lots of people
responded but in the end the project was
spearheaded by a librarian and teacher
named Megan Megan wrote a letter to her
local newspaper asking people if they
had any five cent coins lying around
because there was this American author
who could use them the letter was
printed online and then eventually in
the newspaper and people responded to it
like a lot of people most of the people
who sent coins to Megan had no idea who
I was but they sent them in anyway they
came in three at a time or a hundred at
a time there were letters about how
people's mothers had collected these
coins or about how they were excited for
their coins to go on an adventure I got
letters in Maori talking about the
importance of tuatara and I just want to
pause to note the amount of effort
involved in this like first people had
to read a letter in the paper then they
had to like go find their coins and then
they had to pay at least $1.00 in
postage to
them to Meghan or else go to the trouble
of dropping them off at the school where
Meghan works all for a stranger in
America
and they did this for no reason except
to be kind they had no idea I was going
through a difficult time in my life and
they had no way of knowing how much
their generosity would mean to me that I
would dissolve into tears of gratitude
when thousands and thousands of tuatara
coins arrived in the mail from Meghan we
gave many out on tour but I still have
some and I will try to use them well to
give them out over the course of my life
to those who might need a physical
reminder of how kind people can be and
how just as cruelty and mistrust can
spread so can kindness to the Kiwis who
made this happen if you're watching
thank you I know that you will say it
was just a little thing but little
things matter Hank I'll see you tomorrow